Hello.
I'm Terry Fisher.
This is the ninth of 12
lectures on copyright.
In the seventh and eighth lectures,
I described the four economic rights
enjoyed by the copyright owner, the
rights of reproduction, modification,
distribution, and public performance.
Along the way, I identified several
specific exceptions and limitations.
Each of which narrows the reach of
one of those four economic rights.
In addition to the specific
exceptions that we considered there,
there are in the United
States two general limitations
on copyright entitlements.
In other words, limitations
that are applicable to all four
of the economic rights.
These are the doctrines of
fair use and copyright misuse.
Of the two, fair use is
by far the more important,
so I will concentrate exclusively
on it in this lecture.
If you're curious
about copyright misuse,
you can, of course, explore on
your own the pertinent branch
of the map of copyright law
that accompanies this lecture.
Here's how my presentation
will be organized.
In the first segment
of the lecture, I will
describe the history of the fair
use doctrine in the United States.
In the second segment, I will describe
the shape of the fair use doctrine
today, illustrating my
analysis with examples
drawn from several modern cases.
In the third and final
segment, I will describe
how some countries other
than the United States
attempt to deal with the
issues that in this country
are addressed using fair use.
My hope is that, by the
end, you'll not only
have a sense of how the fair use
doctrine works, but also its merits
and demerits, and how it stacks up
against alternative approaches employed
by other countries.
So let's begin.
The seeds of what would become the
fair use doctrine in the United States
were planted in English law
beginning in the mid 18th century.
Then, in the case of Folsom
vs. Marsh, just a story
relied in part on the
English precedents to hold
that some activities inconsistent
with the US federal copyright statute
nevertheless constituted "Fair
and bona fide abridgments"
or "Justifiable uses," and therefore
did not give rise to liability.
The language in which just his story
purported to distill English cases
was to prove as we'll see influential.
Here's how he put it.
In deciding whether to
excuse a particular use,
one should look to the nature and
objects of the selections made,
the quantity and value
of the materials used,
and the degree in which the
use may prejudice the sale,
or diminish the profits, or supersede
the objects of the original work.
In several other US cases in the
late 19th and early 20th centuries,
federal courts followed
Folsom in excusing
as fair various activities that appeared
to run afoul of the copyright statute.
In these early decisions, the question
of what constituted a fair use
was not crisply
differentiated from the issue
of whether the defendant's
behavior abridged
the plaintiff's exclusive rights.
But by the middle of the 20th
century, courts in the US
had begun consistently
to refer to the concept
of Fair Use as a distinct legal issue.
Specifically, as an affirmative defense
excusing otherwise unlawful conduct.
For most of its history, fair use
was an entirely judge made doctrine.
That changed in 1976 when Congress
revamped the copyright statute,
it acknowledged and approved
the line of judicial decisions
that had created fair use, and
Congress codified those decisions
in Section 107 of the
reconstructed copyright statute.
When codifying fair use
however, Congress made explicit,
but it did not intend to
"freeze" the doctrine.
But rather expected it to continue
to evolve particularly in order
to accommodate "rapid
technological change."
The text of Section 107 is
set forth on your screen.
As you can see it has three parts.
The first maybe thought of
as a general introduction.
It provides "Notwithstanding the
provisions of Section 106 and 106a,
the fair use of a copyrighted work
including such use by reproduction
in copies or phonorecords for
purposes such as criticism, comment,
news reporting, teaching,
scholarship, or research
is not an infringement of copyright."
The most important words in this portion
of the provision are the first eight.
As you can see, they make clear
that Section 107 qualifies
all of the exclusive rights
enjoyed by a copyright owner,
including the Visual Artists Rights
Act, which is embodied in Section 106a.
The middle portion of this
introductory paragraph
appears also to be
important because it seems
to identify a set of activities that
are especially eligible for treatment
as fair uses.
As we will see, however,
the courts have not
given this list of illustrative
activities much weight.
The heart of Section
107 to which the courts
have given a great deal of
weight is the middle portion.
"In determining whether the use made
of a work in any particular case
is a fair use, the
factors to be considered
shall include-- One-- the
purpose and character of the use.
Two-- the nature of
the copyrighted work.
Three-- the substantially
of the portion used.
And four-- the effect of the
use upon the potential market
for the copyrighted work."
Several dimensions of this
paragraph merit emphasis.
Most importantly, fair
use, as you can see,
is an ad hoc case specific doctrine.
It is applied on a case by case basis by
considering the four factors set forth
on the right side of your screen.
No one of these factors
is determinative,
nor is the list of
factors exhaustive as one
can tell by the use of
the verb shall include.
The third segment of Section
107 can be thought of as a coda.
"The fact of the work is
unpublished shall not itself
bar a finding of fair use if such
findings made upon consideration
of all of the above factors."
This provision was added later.
Its purpose was to repudiate some
decisions by the Court of Appeals
for the Second Circuit
that had sharply limited
the availability of the fair
use doctrine for biographers
who quoted in their works, unpublished
letters, diaries, and so forth.
The coda does not grant the
biographers an unqualified privilege
to use such things, but it
reduces the height of the hurdle
that biographers must clear.
Since the adoption of Section
107, the fair use doctrine
has been construed and applied four
times by the United States Supreme
Court.
In three of those four cases, the
court's analysis was elaborate.
In the remaining portion of
this segment of the lecture,
I'll describe the three major cases, the
way in which the Supreme Court resolved
them, and how, as a result, the
fair use doctrine has evolved.
The first of the three
decisions was Sony Corporation
vs. Universal City Studios--
popularly known as the Betamax case.
Here's some background.
The chart set forth on your screen
should by now be familiar to you.
It describes the legal
relationships and business models
and gives shape to the film
industry in the United States.
If any portion of this
diagram is puzzling,
you should review the pertinent
section of lecture number three.
In the 1970s, a significant
portion of the revenues
upon which the film studios depended
came from this segment of the industry.
Specifically, the
license fees the studios
derived from television networks.
Those fees were generated as follows.
You'll recall from the preceding lecture
that the US film studios traditionally
relied on a so-called windowing
system to maximize revenue
they were able to extract from a
heterogeneous group of customers.
We're concerned here with the seventh
of the eight traditional windows.
Roughly two years after a film
was first released in US theaters,
the studio would typically license
it to a television network.
The network would remove material
inappropriate for general audiences,
and divide the film into roughly
10 minute segments inserting
advertisements in
between those segments.
This composite would then be
broadcast to the network's viewers.
The viewers would not pay either the
networks or the studios directly.
Instead, they would
purchase, or so it was
thought, more of the products that were
advertised in the course of the film.
The advertisers paid a portion
of their increased revenue
to the television networks in
the form of advertising fees,
and the networks in turn
paid a portion of those fees
to the studios thus closing the loop.
This system has been running
well for several decades.
Then in the late 1970s,
the Sony Corporation
disrupted it by offering
consumers, for the first time,
affordable and convenient
videocassette recorders known as VCRs.
Sony sold these machines
to a rapidly growing set
of consumers receiving in
return substantial revenue.
I know because I bought one
in 1983 and it wasn't cheap.
One of the functions
of these recorders was
to enable consumers to make copies of
the films broadcast by the television
networks.
Now you might think that
this development would
please the networks and the studios
because the markets for their shows
and films would grow.
But the studios, as it turned out,
were more worried about the likelihood
that viewers would use
their new VCRs to avoid
watching the embedded advertisements.
The simple way of doing this was by fast
forwarding through those advertisements
during the playback of the
tapes-- a technique still commonly
employed by viewers using
more modern technologies.
A more complex way of avoiding
of avoiding the advertisements
was to designate a member of the
family to watch a program when
it was broadcast live, and to pause
the recording whenever advertisements
appeared, thus enabling the
other members of the family
to watch the tape later to avoid
seeing the advertisements altogether.
Advertisers fearing
this effect threatened
to reduce the fees
they paid the networks.
The networks in turn
threatened to reduce
the license fees they paid the studios.
Two of the studios,
Disney and Universal,
decided to try to stop this threat.
How?
In theory, they could have
pursued individual VCR
users for copyright infringement.
As you know by now, making a
verbatim copy of an audio-visual work
violates Section 106.1 of the statute.
That's what the viewers were
doing with their new machines.
So the studios could have brought
infringement suits against the viewers.
They did not for two reasons.
First, there were too many viewers
to make this strategy effective.
Individual lawsuits would have
been hopelessly impractical.
Second, the studios did not wish
to alienate their customers.
So instead, they brought
an infringement action
against Sony, the
manufacturer of the machines
that made this conduct possible.
Now Sony was not making
any copies of any film.
So the studios were unable to
assert that Sony was itself
violating section 106.1 of the statute.
Instead, the studios asserted that Sony
was engaged in contributory copyright
infringement by
facilitating and encouraging
the unlawful behavior of the viewers.
The lawsuit percolated
slowly up through the courts.
The trial court found in favor of Sony.
The ninth circuit reversed.
And finally in 1984, the
United States Supreme Court
decided by a vote of
five to four with Sony,
ruling that it had not engaged in
contributory copyright infringement.
The court's ruling depended
upon two nested propositions
which are listed on your screen.
First, the manufacture
of a device that can
be used to violate the copyright laws
is liable for contributory infringement
only if that device is not "capable
of substantial noninfringing uses."
Second, timeshifting copyrighted
programs is a fair use.
The first of these two
propositions has had a major effect
on the law governing the doctrine of
contributory copyright infringement.
We will return to this
aspect of the Betamax case
when we examine
contributory infringement
doctrine in the 11th
lecture in the series.
For now, our focus is on the
second of the propositions.
Here's a bit more detail
concerning its underpinnings.
The majority of The
Supreme Court pointed out
that VCRs are commonly used for
two quite different purposes.
First, they're sometimes
used for "libraring",
a term the courts invented
to describe taping
broadcast television shows or films with
an expectation of retaining the tapes
and using them to replay the
shows or films repeatedly.
That activity is tacitly
promoted by this advertisement.
Second, VCRs are even
more often employed
to tape shows or films that are
broadcast at a time inconvenient
for the viewer, enabling the viewer
to watch them once at a later time,
whereupon the tapes are erased.
The latter function, promoted
by this advertisement,
the court described as "timeshifting".
Because time shifting is a common use
of the machines, if it were lawful,
Sony could escape liability under
the first of the two holdings.
And the court decided that
timeshifting was indeed
lawful because it qualified as a fair
use under Section 107 of the statute.
And therefore, Sony was home free.
To support its judgment
on this issue, the court
surveyed the four
statutory fair use factors.
With respect to the
first factor, the court
emphasized the fact that the
behavior of the VCR users
was in the court's judgment
noncommercial in character.
Here's how Justice Stevens writing
for the court put the point.
Although not conclusive,
the first factor
requires that the commercial or
nonprofit character of an activity
be weighed in any fair use decision.
If the Betamax were used to make copies
for a commercial or profit making
purpose, such use would
be presumptively unfair.
The contrary presumption is
appropriate here, however,
because the district
court's findings plainly
establish that timeshifting
for private home use
must be characterized as a
noncommercial, nonprofit activity.
Interestingly, Stevens did
not mention in his opinion
the second statutory factor-- the
nature of the copyrighted work,
so we'll leave that box blank.
The third factor-- the
amount of copying--
would seem to disfavor of finding a
fair use, insofar as the VCR users
were making verbatim copies
of entire shows or films.
"Nevertheless, the court ruled
that in light of the fact
that timeshifting
merely enables a viewer
to see such a work which he had been
invited to witness in its entirety
free of charge, the fact that
the entire work is reproduced
does not have its ordinary
effect of militating
against the finding of fair use."
The court thus implied that
this third factor was neutral.
The decisive factor in
the court's judgment
was the fourth-- the magnitude
of the adverse impact
upon the potential market
for the studio's films.
In the court's judgment,
the noncommercial character
of the viewer's activities
cast the burden of proof
with respect to this
factor upon the studios.
Here's how it put the point.
"A challenge to a noncommercial
use of a copyrighted work
requires proof either that
the particular use is harmful.
Or that, if it should
become widespread, it
would adversely affect the potential
market for the copyrighted work.
Actual present harm need
not be shown, nor is it
necessary to show as certainty
that future harm will result.
What is necessary is that showing
by preponderance of the evidence
that some meaningful likelihood
of future harm exists."
In the court's view, the record in the
case-- which had been created in 1978--
failed to establish a likelihood
of economic injury to the studios.
Accordingly, the court
ruled that the fourth factor
inclined in favor of
a finding of fair use.
Finally, the court pointed
to a variable not included
in the statutory list of factors.
"The district court's
conclusions are buttressed
by the fact that to the
extent time shipping
expands public access to freely
broadcast television programs,
it yields societal benefits."
Taking all these variables
into account, the Supreme Court
affirmed the district court's
judgment that timeshifting
should be considered fair.
Justice Blackmun wrote
a dissent in the case,
which was joined by
three other justices.
Blackmun disagreed with the majority
of the justices on two main points.
First, drawing on the
Ninth Circuit's opinion,
he differentiated what he called
ordinary and productive uses
of copyrighted materials.
Suggesting that the latter--
meaning productive uses--
are more likely to qualify
as fair than the former.
Here's how Blackmun made his argument.
"The situations in which fair
use is most commonly recognized
are listed in section 107 itself.
Fair use may be found when a work is
used for purposes such as criticism,
comment, news reporting, teaching,
scholarship, or research.
Each of these uses
reflects a common theme.
Each is a productive use resulting
in some added benefit to the public
beyond that produced by
the first author's work.
The fair use doctrine,
in other words, permits
works to be used for
socially laudable purposes.
I am aware of no case in which
the reproduction of a copyrighted
work for the sole benefit of the
user has been held to be fair use."
Second, Blackmun interpreted
the fourth statutory factor
more expansively than did the majority.
Specifically, Blackmun emphasized the
adjective potential in the statute.
Here's how he interpreted that word.
"The requirement that a putatively
infringing use of the copyrighted work
to be fair must not impair a
potential market for that work
has two implications.
First, and infringer cannot prevail
merely by demonstrating that
the copyright holder suffered no net
harm from the infringer's action.
Indeed, even the showing that
the infringement has resulted it
in a net benefit to the copyright
holder will not suffice.
Rather, the infringer must
demonstrate that he had not
impaired the copyright holder's
ability to demand compensation from,
or to deny access to any
group who would otherwise
be willing to pay to see or
hear the copyrighted work.
Second, the fact that a given
market for a copyrighted work
would not be available
to the copyright holder
were it not for the infringer's
activities does not permit infringer
to exploit that market without
compensating the copyright holder."
Applying this definition of potential
market to the facts of the case,
Blackmun concluded that the
needle tilted toward the studios.
And so far as a finding of fair
use, we deprive them of access
to the "market consisting
of those persons who
find it impossible or inconvenient
to watch the programs at the time
they are broadcast, and who wish
to watch them at other times.
These persons are willing to pay for the
privilege of watching the copyrighted
work at their convenience
as is evidenced by the fact
that they are willing to
pay for VTRs and tapes.
Undoubtedly, most also would be
willing to pay some kind of loyalty
to copyright holders.
The studios correctly argue that
they've been deprived of the ability
to exploit this sizable market."
A majority of the justices, as
you've seen, were unconvinced.
In the many briefs filed
with the Supreme Court--
and in associated
congressional testimony which
was being conducted at more
or less the same time--
the studios and their allies
predicted dire consequences
if Sony escaped liability.
Most lurid was a statement by Jack
Valenti, the president of the MPAA
whom you encountered
in lecture number six.
Valenti famously declared, "The
VCR is to the American film
producer and the American public as the
Boston Strangler is to the woman home
alone."
As it turned out, the result of the
court's decision was not so dire.
Indeed, the film industry seems to
have benefited from the machines.
Box office revenues
did not seem to suffer.
Even more dramatically, the
widespread distribution of VCRs
made possible the emergence of
a new and even more lucrative
market consisting of home
video rentals and purchases.
While the courts were dealing
with the Betamax case,
a second major dispute implicating
the fair use doctrine was brewing.
The facts were very different.
In the late 1970s, former
President Gerald Ford
with a substantial assistance of a
ghost writer wrote an autobiography.
He assigned the copyright in
the book to Harper and Row
in return for a substantial payment.
In 1979 Harper and Row
entered into a contract
with Time Magazine, under which Time
acquired the right to publish excerpts
from the book just before the
publication of the book itself.
Unfortunately for Time, The
Nation Magazine scooped it.
Here's how.
A few weeks before the
Time article was to appear,
an unknown person provided
a copy of the manuscript
to Victor Navaski, who was
then editor of The Nation.
Navaski hastily drafted an
article describing the book.
Included in that article were some 300
words taken from Ford's manuscript.
When The Nation's story
appeared, Time Magazine
canceled its contract
with Harper and Row,
and refused to pay the
balance of the contract price.
Harper and Row thereupon brought
a copyright infringement suit
against The Nation.
Once again, the parties traded victories
as the case wound its way upward
through the judicial system.
The district court ruled in favor of
Harper and Row by a vote of two to one.
Court of Appeals for the
Second Circuit reversed,
ruling that the modest amount of
verbatim copying made by The Nation
should be excused as fair.
The Court of Appeals ruling was in turn
reversed by the United States Supreme
Court by a vote of six to three.
Justice O'Connor, writing
for the court, concluded
that all four of the fair use factors
tilted in favor of the plaintiff.
With respect to the first factor, she
emphasized the following two points.
First, the defendant was making
money from the unauthorized use.
The Betamax opinion, you'll
recall, had included the sentence,
"Every commercial use
of copyrighted material
is presumptively an unfair
exploitation of a monopoly privilege
that belongs to the owner of copyright."
That presumption,
O'Connor ruled, operated
to the disadvantage
of the defendant here
because he was engaged in
a profit making venture.
Second, O'Connor
stressed the illicit way
in which Navaski had gained access
to the plaintiff's manuscript.
This was germane, she
contended, because one dimension
of the "character" of
the defendant's use
is "the propriety of the
defendant's conduct."
Fair use, she insisted, presupposes
good faith and fair dealing.
With respect to the
second statutory factor,
O'Connor conceded that "the law
generally recognizes a greater need
to disseminate factual works than
works of fiction or fantasy."
However, she concluded
that the quotations
Navaski had taken from Ford's manuscript
were more expressive than factual.
Even more important was the
fact that the manuscript
had been unpublished at the time
the defendant acted, and thus
economically especially vulnerable.
With respect to the
third factor, O'Connor
ruled that the assessment of amount must
be as much qualitative as quantitative.
The fact that Navaski had
only taken some 300 words
was less important than the fact that
the portion taken was "essentially
the heart of the book,"
including the precise language
in which Ford explained his
decision to pardon Richard Nixon.
Like the court in the
Betamax case, O'Connor
placed greatest weight on
the fourth and final factor.
But she defined the phrase "potential
market" in the fourth factor
more broadly than had just
Stevens in the Betamax case.
Citing Justice Blackmun's
Betamax dissent,
O'Connor ruled that "to
negate fair use, one
need only show that if the challenged
use should become widespread,
it would adversely affect the potential
market for the copyrighted work.
This inquiry must take into account
not only harm to the original,
but harm to the market
for derivative works."
Application of that framework
to the facts of this case
plainly favored the
plaintiff, she ruled,
because Time Magazine's decision to
cancel the contract with Harper and Row
cost it significant revenue.
The bottom line is the
fair use defense failed.
The third of the three cases
arrived in the Supreme Court
almost a decade later.
Where as the Betamax case, as we
saw, involved audio-visual works,
and the Harper and Row case
involved literary works,
this one involved music.
The plaintiff was Acuff-Rose
Music, a music publisher
that held the copyright in the
composition, "Oh, Pretty Woman",
originally written by Roy Orbison, the
person who is depicted on your screen.
Here's an excerpt of Orbison's
rendition of his composition.
[MUSIC ROY ORBISON, "OH, PRETTY WOMAN"]
In 1989, Luther Campbell, one of the
members of the rap group, 2 Live Crew,
wrote a song that he characterized
as a parody of Orbison's composition.
Here's an excerpt of 2 Live Crew's
rendition of Campbell's song.
[MUSIC -- 2 LIVE CREW, "PRETTY WOMAN"]
Before this recording was released,
the manager of 2 Live Crew
sought a license from
Acuff-Rose, but was refused.
2 Live Crew released
the recording anyway.
A year later, after roughly
200,000 copies have been sold,
Acuff-Rose brought a
copyright infringement suit.
Now you might wonder why 2 Live Crew
did not rely upon the Section 115
so-called cover license that
we've discussed previously,
which would have allowed them to
release the recording without permission
provided they paid
Acuff-Rose a modest fee which
they seemed to have been going to do.
The reason is that, as
you'll recall, I hope,
the Section 115 license is
only available to a musician
who makes a cover that does
not alter "the basic melody
or fundamental character"
of the composition at issue.
2 Live Crew, as you
might expect, conceded
that they could not
satisfy that requirement.
As a result, the only basis on which 2
Live Crew might have avoided liability
was fair use.
Once again, the courts that
consider the case split.
The trial court ruled that 2 Live Crew
was shielded by the fair use doctrine.
The Court of Appeals for the Sixth
Circuit reversed by a vote of two
to one, and the United
States Supreme Court in turn
reversed the Court of Appeals,
this time in a unanimous opinion.
Although technically, the
Supreme Court remanded the case
for further proceedings, its
ruling was widely and rightly
interpreted as a
victory for 2 Live Crew.
Although Justice Souter,
writing for the court,
purported to merely be applying
well settled principles.
In fact, his opinion represented
a substantial reconfiguration
of the fair use doctrine.
The most important of the shifts
implicit, in Souter's opinion,
concerned factor number one.
You'll recall that in the Betamax
case, Justice Blackmun, in dissent,
had differentiated ordinary from
productive uses of copyrighted works,
arguing unsuccessfully that the
latter deserved wider latitude when
applying the fair use doctrine.
And Campbell, just as Souter,
tacitly adopted Blackmun's position.
The crucial language is on your screen.
"The first factor in a fair use
inquiry is the purpose and character
of the use.
The central purpose
of this investigation
is to see, in Justice Story's
words, whether the new work merely
supersedes the objects
of the original creation.
Or instead adds something new with a
further purpose or different character,
altering the first with new
expression, meaning, or message.
It asks, in other words, whether
and to what extent the new work is
'transformative.' Although such
transformative use is not absolutely
necessary for a finding
of fair use," citing Sony,
"the goal of copyright is to promote
science and the arts in that goal is
generally furthered by the
creation of transformative works.
Such works thus lie at the
heart of the fair use doctrine
to guarantee of breathing space within
the confines of copyright," citing
Blackmun, "and the more
transformative the new work, the less
will be the significance of
other factors like commercialism
that may weigh against
a finding of fair use."
The principles set forth in
this paragraph, as we will see,
have colored all subsequent
fair use jurisprudence.
Applying this approach to the
facts of the Campbell case,
the Supreme Court
announced broadly "parody
is an obvious claim to
transformative value."
What then constitutes a parody?
The court offered several
definitions, including the following.
"'Modern dictionaries accordingly
describe a parity as a literary
or artistic work that imitates the
characteristic style of an author,
or a work, for comic effect or ridicule.
Or, as a composition in prose or verse,
in which the characteristics turns
of thought and phrase, and an author or
class of authors are imitated in such
a way as to make them appear
ridiculous.' For the purposes
of copyright law, the nub of the
definitions and the heart of any
parodist's claim to quote
from existing material,
is the use of some elements of a prior
author's composition to create a new
one that, at least in part,
comments on that author's works."
All of the justices,
except Justice Kennedy,
seemed satisfied that 2 Live Crew's
song fit within this definition,
and thus that the first statutory
factor favored the defendant.
To be sure, the Supreme
Court did not rule
that any work that falls
within this definition
automatically qualifies as fair.
On the contrary, the court announced
that "parody, like any other use,
has to work its way through
the relevant statutory factors
and be judged case by case in light
of the ends of copyright law."
However, as we will
see, the way in which
the court worked those statutory
factors strongly favored parodists.
With respect to the
second factor, the court
conceded that Orbison's song "fell
within the core of copyright's
protective purposes," but it discounted
the significance of that fact
when the defendant's work
consists of a parody.
You'll recall that in
the Harper and Row case,
Justice O'Connor
countered the third factor
against Victor Navaski
on the grounds that he
had taken the heart of
President Ford's biography.
In the Campbell case,
the Court of Appeals
relied in part on O'Connor's language
when ruling against 2 Live Crew.
Justice Souter, writing
for the Supreme Court,
appeared to agree with the premise.
Namely that 2 Live Crew had taken
the heart of Orbison's song.
However, Souter did not
consider that fact fatal.
Here's the way he put the point.
"If quotation of the opening
riff and the first line
may be said to go to the
heart of the original,
the heart is also what most readily
conjures up the song for parody.
And it is the heart at
which parody takes aim.
Copying does not become excessive
in relation to parodic purpose
merely because the portion
taken was the original's heart.
If 2 Live Crew had copied a
significantly less memorable part
of the original, it is
difficult to see how
its parodic character
would come through."
The Supreme Court did
not definitively resolve
the application of the fourth factor.
Instead remanding the
case to the lower courts
for reconsideration of this issue.
But the guidelines that Souter
provided the lower courts strongly
suggested that the outcome of that
inquiry would favor 2 Live Crew.
In particular, the Supreme Court
repudiated the "presumption
that the Court of Appeals
had quite plausibly derived
from the Betamax and
Harper and Row opinions.
Namely the presumption that commercial
uses of copyrighted materials give
rise to injuries to the
market for the original work."
Souter and Campbell limited the
scope of that ostensible presumption
to the context of "verbatim
copying of the original
in its entirety for
commercial purposes."
No such presumption, he
contended, is appropriate
when the defendant's use is
transformative as in parody.
The likely result, the 2 Live Crew
song would qualify as a fair use.
So this concludes our review
of the way in which fair use
doctrine in the United States
evolved from its inception
in the early 19th century
through the Campbell case.
In the next segment of the lecture,
we'll consider the shape of fair use
today.